اقتحمت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المسجد
الاقصى المبارك قبل صلاه الفجر وبعدها
واعتدت على المصلين والمعتكفين مخلفه
اصابات بينهم قبل ان تقوم باعتقال المئات
منهم وفيما قالت السلطه الفلسطينيه ان
ممارسات حكومه نتنياهو ستشعل الحرائق في
المنطقه تواعدت الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالرد
على ما وصفته بالجريمه غير المسبوقه بحق
الاقصى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساراته ما هي الحسابات
الداخليه والخارجيه التي تدفع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليمينيه المتطرفه الى
استفزاز مشاعر الفلسطينيين باقتحام المسجد
الاقصى وضربه واعتقال المصلين والمعتكفين
فيه ما هي خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه في
التعامل مع الموقف الراهن والى اي مدى
ستذهب قوى المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الرد
على التصعيد بعدما شهده قطاع غزه من اطلاق
للصواريخ باتجاه مستوطنات اسرائيليه ما هي
مقالات المشهد في الضفه وغزه وعموم
المنطقه على ضوء دعوات وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى مزيد من التصعيد العسكري
كيف تبدو المواقف العربيه والدوليه ازاء
هذا المشهد
[موسيقى]
ليلى صعبه مره بهالمجد الاقصى هكذا وصف
ناشطون مقديسيون ما اقدمت عليه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من اقتحام واعتداء
واعتقالات بين المصلين والمعتكفين في
المسجد تصعيد جاء بتشجيع من جماعات يهوديه
متطرفه تواعدت فصائل فلسطينيه بالرد عليه
السلطه الفلسطينيه قالت انما يقوم به
الاحتلال من مساس بالمقدسات يمثل حربا
شعوا على الشعب الفلسطيني والامه العربيه
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل
هنيه قال انما يجري في الاقصى المبارك
جريمه غير مسبوقه وسيكون لها ما بعدها
اسرائيليا قال رئيس الوزراء بنيامينه ياهو
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعمل على الحفاظ
على الوضع الراهن وتهدئه الموقف في
المقابل دعا وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
الى شن ما سماها عمليه السور الواقع اثنان
في الضفه الغربيه وان تبدا بنابلس وجنين
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اكد ان احداث الاقصى زادت التوتر في غزه
والضفه في اشاره الى قصف ستيروت بصواريخ
وغارات شنها الجيش الاسرائيلي على مواقع
في قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من تل
ابيب ران ادلست الكاتب الصحفي والمحلله
السياسيه سيد ران ما هي حسابات نتنياهو في
هذا التصعيد الاخير في المسجد الاقصى
اذا اردنا ان نفهم ما الذي يحصل حاليا في
الاقصى
يجب ان ننظر الى الصوره الاشمل ليس فقط ما
حصل في الامس وهو امر فظيع بالنسبه الى كل
الموجودين هناك ولكن ما يحصل من حوله في
اسرائيل نحن الان عالقون بين نوعين من
الحروب الداخليه والخارجيه مع جيراننا
وفي خضم هذه الفوضى وهي فعلا فوضى كارثيه
بالنسبه الى اسرائيل لانه داخل اسرائيل
هناك
خلاف حول هويه جانبين
اولا مسار التحول نحو الديكتاتوريه وثانيا
المسار لتحول الى ديمقراطيه لبراليه في
خدم كل ذلك
يحصل ما يحصل الان في الاقصى وهو قد يكون
محفزا لحرب كبيره وهي ليست بمزحه حين
اتحدث عن حرب كبرى هذه الحرب الكبرى قد
تكون نتيجه سوء حسابات حين يكون هناك سوء
تفسير لما يقوم به الطرف الاخر انتم
تعرفون ما اقصد هذا قد يؤدي الى حرب كبرى
المشكله
من من يعني ما المقصود بسوء حسابات عندما
تتحدث عن سوء حسابات سوء حسابات من اي طرف
من الاطراف كلها من الطرفين حين يكون
لدينا طرف قد يسيء فهم ما يقوم به الطرف
الاخر
او مثلا يحصل
شيء ما يحاول طرف ما
يسيطر على الوضع ويسيء الطرف الاخر تفسيره
وهذا قد يؤدي الى حرب كبرى المشكله في هذه
الحرب الحرب الكبرى الان
هي انها تختلف عما حصل من قبل لان الحرب
الكبرى الان اذا وقعت بين اسرائيل
وجيراننا تعرفون البيئه نفسها نتحدث عن
لبنان وحزب الله هو سوريا وغزه والضفه
الغربيه
بصوره عامه مع ايران المشكله هي انها لن
تكون
مشكله او حربا على الارض بل بين اطلاقي
صواريخ وصواريخ مضاده
ومحاوله
لانجاز اكبر قدر ممكن من حيث الضحايا
والدمار
هذا هذا فيما يتعلق بامكانيه او تداعيات
ما يجري الى اين يمكن ان يذهب المشهد ولكن
المسافه في الخطاب بين نتنياهو ووزرائه
وخاصه وزير الماليه ووزير الامن كيف يمكن
ان نفهمها ان نفهمها
انا شخصيا ارى في ذلك اننا عالقونا الان
بين ايدي المتطرفين
نتانياهو
وبنجفير
وزير الامن الداخلي كلاهما
متطرف
وارى ان كل منهما يعمل برايي ضد مصالح
اسرائيل
اذا السبيل الى خروج من هذه المشكله عن
التهدئه والعمل على التهدئه بينما
سنطرشفير يتحدثون عن ضروره التصعيد
انا لا اعتقد انهم يريدون الاستمرار في
التصعيد هم يريدون ان يستمروا في
ما يشبه التصعيد ظاهريا لان التصعيد
الفعلي هو سوف يؤدي الى مع ذكرته من قبل
اي حمام دم لا ينتهي لا يقبله احد
ولكن سوء التفسير وسوء الحسابات هذا سوف
يؤدي الى الكارثه السبيل الوحيد للخروج من
ذلك هو طبعا التخلص من الحكومه وهذا ما
ادعو له مع انه ربما قد لا يحصل ولكن
السبيل الى ذلك هو استخدام
قوه التوازن نحن في اسرائيل نعتبر الدوله
الاقوى في المنطقه
وبالتالي تقع المسؤوليه على اكتافنا انا
فعلا امل ان تاخذ حكومتنا هذه المسؤوليه
على محمل الجدوى كما يجب وتحاول ان تمضي
قدما من اجل تهدئه هذا التوتر ولكن الشرق
الاوسط كما نعرف معروف ان التوتر فيه ليس
مجرد وضع عابر ولكنه سياسه اذا فهمتم قصدي
الامر معقد اعرف ذلك ولكن هذه طريقه
تصرفنا الان في اسرائيل وفي المناطق
المجاوره ايضا في الدول المجاوره
الكاتبه الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي كنت معنا من تل ابيب وحول نفس
الموضوع ينضم الينا من الناصره ايهاب
جبارين الكاتب الصحفي المختصه في الشؤون
ومن غزه الدكتور صالح النعامي الخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه ابدا معك سيد ايهاب
جبارين سيد ايهاب يعني الذي جرى في المسجد
الاقصى اين يمكن ان نضعه ضمن المعارك التي
يخوضها نتنياهو هو يقود اكثر حكومه يمنيه
متطرفه ما هو الهدف من هذا التصعيد
بتقديرك
نعم مساء الخير هذه المرحله تقودها مثلث
من ثلاثه اضلاع الضلع الاول نحن نتحدث عن
الاجهزه الامنيه بدون ادنى شك والتي تحاول
ان يعني تعود الى الصوره بعد عده
محاولات لضعضعت مكانتها ان كان في الداخل
داخليا في داخل اسرائيل وحتى خارجيا على
المستوى
المناطق والدول المجاوره بالنسبه لاسرائيل
حيث يعني كانوا قد صرحوا بانها فقدت
افضليه الرد في عده مرات في الاسابيع
الاخيره هذا من جهه ومن الضلع الثاني نحن
نتحدث عن
نتنياهو والضلع الثالث نحن نتحدث
عنهم استراتيجيته الخاصه ولكل منهن هو
يحاول ان ياخذ مزامع الامور الى مناطق
اخرى بالنسبه لبين يمين نتنياهو وبالنسبه
للاجهزه الامنيه تحديدا في هذه المره
هنالك نوع من التوافق هم يريدون ان يخلقوا
نوع من
تسمى بالتواتر لهذه التصعيدات يعني ربما
هنا اوافق مع ما قاله
السيد رائد سابقا بان هنالك يعني نوع من
الحفاظ على التواتر لا يوجد النيه لهذين
الطرفين تحديدا للتصعيد لكن التواتر
والتغيير الامر الواقع هو ما يعملون عليه
يعني المشاهد التي كنا قد رايناها يوم امس
هي مشاهد يعني
سابقه في هذا ولكن
دون الوصول الى تصعيد حسب ما تقول
هذه هذه النقطه تحديدا بالنسبه يعني
لطالما اعتدنا او اعتادت اسرائيل ان تسوق
رمضان وكانه شهر يعني ما تسميه شهر
الارهاب وشهر العنف وما الى ذلك وتحاول ان
تلقي كل مزاعم فشلها على هذا الشهر الكريم
لانها لم تستطع ان تحافظ على لا على الامن
بالنسبه
لمواطنيها داخليا ولم تستطع ان تحافظ على
ما تسمى هي استراتيجيه الهدف فبالتالي هي
تحاول ان تلقي بكل فشلها على هذا الشهر
وتحاول ان تصعد في هذا الشهر لهدفين الهدف
الاول مبدئيا لكي تحاول ان تستعطف كل
القوى اليمنيه في العالم الاسلامي فوبيا
تحديدا لكي تتعاطف معها ومع قضيتها من جهه
والقضيه الثانيه ان تلقي بهذا على الدين
الاسلامي محاوله ان تجور الصراع الى صراع
ديني لا صراع قومي لان هنالك هذه الورقه
تجد فيها نوع من الافضليه الان هذا من جهه
من جهه ثانيه بالنسبه لبين يمين نتنياهو
في هذه النقطه على مدى الثلاث سنوات
الاخيره كان هنالك تحديدا العام الماضي
كان هنالك رقم قياسي في عدد الاقتحامات
المسجد الاقصى نحو نتحدث عن 4000 وستمائه
وخمسه اقتحام خلال عيد الفصح لوحده تحديدا
وما قبل ذلك كنا نتحدث عن 2600 اقتحام في
نفس الفتره الان الهدف بالنسبه هو حكومه
اليمين هي ان تضاعف هذا الرقم على الاقل
تقدير ان تصل الى 6000 اقتحام خلال هذه
الفتره لكي تحاول ان تضع هذه الورقه
الانتخابيه على الطاوله يعني ساعود ان كان
ان كانت العلاقه او هنالك توافق بينما
سميته بالاضلع الثلاثه ام هنالك اختلاف في
وجهات النظر ولكن دعني اسمع من الدكتور
صالح دكتور صالح النعامي
اليوم هنالك تصعيد وبعض التصعيد وبعض
الخيار الامني الذي توجهت له الحكومه
الاسرائيليه منذ ان وصلت الى السلطه منذ
ان وصل نتنياهو الى السلطه يعود نتنياهو
للحديث عن التهدئه اذا لماذا التصعيد
والخيارات الامنيه ويعود مره جديده للحديث
عن التهدئه كيف يمكن ان نفهم ذلك
يعني في الحقيقه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو يتعاطيها
مع الشان الفلسطيني تحت تقع تحت ثلاث
محددات رئيس المحدد الاول هو تعاظم دور
المركبات المركبات اليمين الديني فيها
وتحديدا حركتي المنعه اليهوديه برئاسه
الثمار بن جبير وزير الامن القومي
والصهيونيه الدينيه برئا برئاسه بتلال
هاتان الحركتان تدفعان نحو اسره مواصله
استراتيجيه حسم الصراع لذلك نجد عمليه
اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى والتصعيد في جميع
مدن ضفه الغربيه ياتي في هذا في اطار هذه
الاستراتيجيه اسرائيل الحكومه الحاليه
يعني تحاول ان تقطع مع الاستراتيجيات التي
او الاستراتيجيه التي تبناتها كل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه من ال67 حتى تشكل هذه الحكومه
استراتيجيه اداره الصراع النقطه الثانيه
انه هذه
هذه الحركات
الصهيونيه الدينيه والمناعه ليوديها
تنتميان الى ما يسمى التيار الديني
الخلاصي هذا التيار الذي يؤمن بوجوب يعني
يؤمن بفكره نزول المخلص المنتظر الذي يجب
ان يسبقه بناء الهيكل على انقراض المسجد
الاقصى لذلك هؤلاء جدون في مساله في مساله
السماح لليهود او المستوطنين اليهود
بتدنيس المسجد الاقصى ومساله الذبح
القرابين الى غير ذلك النقطه الثانيه وهي
نقطه مهمه انه
مكانه من يمين نتنياهو تراجعت كثيرا بعدما
قام بتاجيل البث في الاصلاحات القضائيه
تحت ضغط الشارع ولاحظنا كيف انه قدم
لاتمار بن جبير تنازل لم يكن يحلم به
اعتماد بن جبير عندما وافق على بتشكيل
ميليشيا مسلحه تابعه لتمار بن جبير وهي
ميليشيا الحرس الوطني النقطه الثالثه في
هذا السياق انه ايضا من يمين نتناهم في
هذا الجو من التصعيد لانه هو معني بفرض
اجنده امنيه امنيه تخلص التركيز على مساله
الاحتجاجات ضد
الصحاحات القضائيه وهو يحاول ان يعبر عن
ان تندمج كل هذه العوامل لاجل التاثير
وفرض جدول امني يختلف عن الجدول الذي
تحاول القوى الليبراليه في اسرائيل فرض
ذلك
ولكن حتى قبل ما جرى فجر هذا اليوم كان
هنالك توتر امني مستمر اذا لماذا الذهاب
لاستفزاز الفلسطينيين والمسلمين في شهر
رمضان بهذه الطريقه
يعني التوتر الامني لم يتوقف منذ ان وصلت
هذه الحكومه الى السلطه
لا هو الان في ظرف يعني ظرف زمني محدد هو
الاحتفاء بمساله عيد الفصح وكما تعلمين
عشيه الاحتفال الاحياء عيد الفصح اليهودي
هناك ما يسمى تقليد ذبح القرابين فلذلك
جاءت اليوم الدعوات المنظمات الهيكل
لاقتحام المسجد الاقصى وذبح القرابين في
هذه المنظمات اعلنت عن عن يعني جائزه
بقيمه عشرين الف شيكل اي موازي 5700 دولار
لكل اليهودي يمكن يتمكن من ذبح نعم طيب
اعود اليك مره جديده سيد ايهاب اشرت الى
الاضلع الثلاثه وكذلك الدكتور صالح
النعامه تحدث عن هذه المسافه اللفظيه او
بالتصريحات يعني
وزير الماليه يتحدثون بلغه فيها اكثر من
التصعيد من نتنياهو الان هل هنالك توافق
توزيع ادوار بين الثلاثه ام لا بالفعل
هنالك اختلاف في المواقف بين نتنياهو
ووزرائه
يعني من يقود من في هذه المرحله يعني
بالضبط اظن اظن يعني هذه ياتي هذا التوتر
في ظل مئه يوم لحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
تقريبا اردنا ان نلخص المئه يوم لحكومه
بنيه يمين نتنياهو يمكن ان نقول انها مئه
يوم من الذروه في العمل السياسي للصهيونيه
الدينيه ومئه يوم من الفشل الذريع لبين
يمين نتنياهو هذه او من اسوا فترات حكومات
بين يمين نتنياهو اظن ان بين يمينه
نتنياهو يعني مكرها ينجر وراء
في بعض الامور واظن ان التوتر الاخير او
ما يحاول ان يجره بين لا يوفق ما بين يمين
نتني وبين يمين نتنياهو يريد هذا التوتر
لكي يحاول ان يخلق نوع من ضباب الحرب
وضباب الخوف سياسه الخوف والبيرانويا هي
سياسه التي يتقنها بين يمينه
نتنياهو تغذى منها على كل مدار الخمس
حكومات التي ادارها سابقا لكي يبقى في ظل
السلطه اي انه اذا ذهب بين سوف ياتي او ما
يسمى يعني اذا اردنا نقتبس بينه الغول
وياكلكم انا هنا لكي احافظ عليكم هذه
السياسه والاستراتيجيه التي تبناها الان
يعني الامر الذين يذهبون اليه في نهايه
المطاف هو الا تصعيد وتحديدا تصعيد في ظل
الحكومه متفككه يمكن القول ولربما لا يريد
ذلك بين يمينه الان لديه حكومه متفككه
لديه حزب لكود متفكك لديه استطلاعات لا
تبشر اليه بالخير وضع اقتصادي من اسوء
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه نظف الى ذلك التعديلات
القضائيه التي مجمع ان يقوم بها التوتر
الدبلوماسي والعلاقات الخارجيه في ذلك
المحور الاهم ونحن الضلع الذي كنت اشهد
اليه لاجهزه الامنيه هنالك توتر لم يكن
مسبوقا ابدا ما بين حكومات اسرائيل
والاجهزه الامنيه الموازيه لها يمكن القول
يعني الحكومات اسرائيليه من ترسم السياسات
لكن اليه التنفيذ يبقى دائما في يد
الاجهزه الامنيه والاجهزه الامنيه كانت
كيف تعطي الهدايا والقرابين يعني الدم
والضحايا الفلسطينيه تقدمهم كقرابين
لحكومات اسرائيل تحديدا في هذه المرحله
اظن ان الاجهزه الامنيه غير معنيه ان تقدم
ايه هدايا لحكومات اسرائيل البته لان من
ذلك يمكن ان يزيد من شعبيه بنيامين
يتنياهو كانه هو الذي يعرف كيف يمسك
الامور بقبضه من حديد هذا بدايه واضف الى
ذلك ان اي تصعيد ممكن ان يجوع الى المنطقه
يعني ربما هنا اوافق في تلك النقطه بما
جاء به ضيفك السابق ران انها يمكن ان
المنطقه الى نوع من التصعيدات على اكثر من
جبهه والاجهزه الامنيه لا تريد ان تخوض في
هذه الجبهات في كابينات متواجد به بنك
سيدي النعامه دكتور صالح النعامي يعني
وكانك لا توافق على بعض التحليل من سيد
ايهاب لك الرد او يعني ايضاح موقفك من ما
قاله سيد ايهاب ولكن في الوقت عينه في ظل
استفاده نتنياهو من هذا التوتر
ماذا يمكن ان تقوم به السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ما هي الخيارات امام السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وماذا عن فصائل
المقاومه
يعني اولا فيما يتعلق بموضوع موقف الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه علينا كنا الان نسمع
وكما تبثون دائما يعني على مدى عده اشهر
كل يوم هناك ضريبه من الدم يدفعها
الفلسطينيون بسبب ما تقوم به الاجل جيش
والاجهزه الامنيه والذي قام تولى القمع
بناء على تعليمات اعتماد هي شرطه الاحتلال
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان هناك تمت يعني تباين
في هذا الموضوع هناك تباينات في موضوع
الصلاحيات صلاحيات ما بين ثمار بن جبير
ومفتش عام الشرطه ولكن بشكل عام هذه
المؤسسه اكثر تطرفا من المستوى السياسي
الان فيما يتعلق بالسلطه الفلسطينيه كما
تعلمين السلطه بررت مشاركتها في اجتماعي
العقبه وشرم الشيخ بانها ذهبت الى هناك من
اجل حمايه الشعب الفلسطيني والان بعد هذه
الاجتماعات كما تلاحظون السلطه تكتفي
للاسف الشديد فقط بالتحليل
بالبيانات
دفع ضريبه كلاميه في الوقت الذي لم تمس
طابع نمط العلاقه مع اسرائيل يعني التعاون
الامني على قدم الوسائط هناك اعتقالات
تتواصل ضد عناصر المقاومه في الضفه من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه في نفس الوقت الذي تقوم
باسرائيل فيه بمداهمه هذه المدن مدن الضفه
الغربيه الان بامكان السلطه يعني لا احد
يتوقع من السلطه ان تقوم باطلاق صواريخ
على اسرائيل ولا ان تطلق النار على
اسرائيل لكن هناك
احياء المقاومه لان الوقت انتهى
حدود كما تعلمين الفصائل الفلسطينيه اطلقت
اليوم صواريخ ردا على ما تم في المسجد
الاقصى وقبل ذلك اطلق الصواريخ على
الممارسات الاسرائيلي ضد اصرف السجون
الاحتلال ولكن هذا نعم شكرا على المقاطعه
انتهى الوقت الوقت الدكتور صلاح النعامي
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من
غزه والشكر موصول للسيد ايهاب جبارين
الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه من الناصره
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]